see how it's
it's synced up a little bit
[Applause]
the timeline is breaking but who broke
it
is it the chicken or the egg oh and if
you think that's cool empty
check out this could it have been synced
this way
this the drop is it an egg of the voodoo
doll he's got on his
desk there i think so did he just drop
agatha
oh my god they planned it they blamed
this whole thing
empty it has to be an agatha voodoo doll
or could it be a different uh voodoo
doll hold on hold on
wait oh my god it's boom are you looking
for this
every every drop in the mcu kang just
caused
that's what that means that's what
happens when you play things side by
side it means causality
it's that boom are you looking for the
ability to walk
because rhodey is welcome back to new
rockstars
did the breaking of the sacred timeline
in loki open
up the multiverse syncing perfectly with
one division's post-credits scene
or could wanda becoming the scarlet
witch have been the true trigger that
broke the timeline
these shows have got to be connected but
how
which came first the ship a thesis or
white visions panic attack
wait a day minute minute
this is inside marvel loki's first
season is complete
but we are still digesting clues for the
way this series will connect
or might have already connected to the
rest of the mcu
i'm eric voss here trying to answer your
lingering questions
from loki with mt mt it's our first
wednesday without loki how has this week
been for you how are you feeling today
um it's hard to process a week without
um a loki in my life or some type of
loki variant
um i mean i already had to go about two
weeks without gator loki and um i'm dead
inside eric i'm just dead
it's hard it's hard but we're getting
through it together because you know
what here on
youtube the season never ends we're just
going to keep making
videos on this until our questions are
answered or until
uh something else distracts us like a
spider-man no way home trailer please
please god please
well last week in our immediate reaction
to the loki finale i pointed out how the
sacred timeline shattering into a
multiverse could have been connected to
that one division post-credits scene
when she heard her sons calling to her
from another reality maybe that was the
opening up of the realities there
now in the days since the loki one
division connection has been a huge
point of discussion
lots of theories out there including
this discovery by tick talker brian
walker
who claims that if you play the season
finales of loki and one division
at the same time starting them both at
the same time in their respective run
times
the moment he who remains realizes
they've crossed the threshold
lines up with the moment wanda powers up
into the scarlet witch
and uh also the object he drops syncs up
with agatha's fall
i love this dark side of the rainbow
[ __ ] it's so right
much i dig it it's so great
um in this episode we're gonna explore
the true timeline between loki and
wandavision
which crisis caused which and what the
true nexus event of marvel phase four
has been so far because we still don't
really know what the nexus event that
caused all this could be a few different
things really
okay okay now uh quick announcement the
loki gator polo shirt from new
rockstarsmirch.com
i'm sorry you missed your chance it's
sold out in record time i mean it's
gator loki of course it was gonna yeah
we told you we told you he doesn't stick
around that guy doesn't linger
he comes he's got quick little feats you
got quick little feats he's going
they're faster than you think you gotta
run in zigzags that's it
classic florida truism that we read
but uh the good news is when it comes to
remarks there's still other
really really cool loki inspired merch
options available for a limited time
though like mobius on a jet ski shirt
uh our gator loki's stickers uh our loki
and black widow-inspired latest
obsession shirts that i am wearing
and mt you have the black widow and the
red deep
yeah looking great now when you buy the
latest obsession shirt at
newrockstarsmerch.com it not only
supports new rockstars but also unlocks
the ability to write in additional
custom shout outs that will appear at
the bottom of your screen like we got
randy lewis who says love you in our
do you think the [ __ ] miss minutes
refers to is the sphinx parked outside
the elite portal referring to that
episode five one
i don't know i think she was stalling in
that moment but she was definitely
stalling for time is the sphinx a
ship is it a vessel well it is it's a
vessel for king the conqueror um
version
so like that could have been what like
the vessel that you know he who remains
used when he was conquered
when he was conquering goliath or
controlling him or like when he first
arrived
to the void so like that is actually a
uh a very important piece of
landmarks there in that fifth episode so
yes i
love it uh what else we have malachi
vera who says who would win in a fight
thor or captain
marvel captain marvel is powered in the
mcu
by derivative energy from the
space stone thor is an asgardian
god uh i think as guardians
uh might not be as powerful as eternals
right you gotta look back at their power
ranking it's weird i think the fact that
uh captain marvel can go
binary in the comics makes her pretty
god level at least uh but thor can live
upwards of 5000 years just you know
aging naturally
uh i mean if we're just talking mcu i
mean just given with like what captain
marvel did to thanos in endgame
and like versus thor struggling with
thanos i think
for the mcu anyway maybe captain marvel
may uh be a little bit stronger here but
i don't know yeah
it's hard because like you gotta look at
the context and the
in the weapons they were using using
stormbreaker
thor would have had thanos even with all
six
infinity stones powered up uh with the
experience of using those stones
so let's say thor with stormbreaker in
peak condition
is pretty unstoppable uh whereas thanos
and captain marvel they were able to
lock horns there
but just by taking out the power stone
and punching her with it
so i think based off of that whatever
that is commutative property of
mathematics i think
i think that that's perfect they make
that logic makes perfect sense
we also got uh daniel tan down here he
says lauren balaz
uh i love you so much and thanks to new
rockstars we get to goob with the
greatest
oh we love gooping with you i love going
with you lauren and daniel
you guys are so nice this is so nice
daniel this is very smart i love that
you did this
thank you again get the latest obsession
shirt today before it
is gone at newrockstarsmerch.com the
black widow inspired ladies obsession
shirt is only going to be around for a
short time as well along with the red
ledger journal newaxersmerch.com
all right mt what's our uh big question
for this episode wait a damn minute
are the finales of loki in one division
synchronized
yeah let's talk about the timeline here
currently on the disney plus platform
their mcu and chronological order
listing
places loki before one division perhaps
just going by the logic that
loki's branch forms from the 2012 point
and then it just kind of jumps around on
the timeline
whereas one division is set one month
after avengers end game in fall 2023
but in truth the tva seems to exist
outside of time even though the final
shot seemed to imply that
this new tva was a variable and thus
maybe linked to a specific timeline but
either way the citadel for sure exists
outside the timeline
uh and from that citadel he remains can
look out at the timeline ring that
orbits him
and see the past see the future to see
all of it all together that was that
alan watts audio in the opening seconds
that kind of teased
that time does not uh you know just move
in one direction
time for he remains is not linear so all
the events of loki are really taking
place
at the same time of every other mcu
event including wandavision
so however you want to sync up this uh
final moment of the sacred timeline
breaking apart you're technically not
wrong to do that because it is taking
place aside
every other mcu event we've seen uh so
if you can derive meaning from the way
it connects to
um you know thor in the dark world or
ant-man running down the steps
or uh getting a tug of war with his dad
you're right you're not wrong it's okay
it can literally happen
anytime it's a very wibbly-wobbly
timey-wimey type of situation and those
are technical terms mcu is using he gets
those directly from astrophysicist
whibley
exactly uh so this whole discovery of
wanda powering up into the scarlet witch
around the same time stamp as the moment
he remains felt that threshold
it's a it's a super interesting thing
though yes you know
looking at this logically it probably is
just a coincidence
uh because we also have to recognize
that it's just highly unlikely that the
editors of both these shows sat down in
a meeting together to synchronize these
moments
wrap their entire episodes around
exactly what the time code would be
i mean who knows i mean maybe
retroactively like marvel and kevin
feige
i know i know this for a fact i do work
on tv shows i know how these things are
made
this is true but like i'm saying maybe
retroactively marvel and kevin feige
are seeing all of these theories i'm
just like maybe we could just say
like like with mark like what marvel did
with iron man 2 and the kid that um
uh iron man saves in at the expo like
yeah that was tom holland all the time
maybe they could just be like oh yeah
that's when the threshold happened blah
blah blah
whatever yeah and just like red caught
it you're right
mt marvel doesn't love easter eggs and
kevin feige is aware of this
on twitter this week when he did the
black widow watch party he
recognized the val tva uh yeah it was so
cool
but he said we didn't think of it he
could have in that moment just taken
credit for it but he didn't
uh i think it's one thing to say that
one character who's a seemingly
um throwaway character is someone of
greater importance
but to say to force your editor to
re-edit
a specific moment because this just
isn't how marvel typically does easter
eggs uh retconning specific characters
and and putting set details in the
background or
uh you know something like a23 or a
visual effect or something like that
yeah for sure
but i think this is just really the
result of this is how tv shows are made
episodic story structure
is a tight formula folks despite it
seeming like oh it's art it's art no
there is like a formula that they follow
and the narrative climax more often than
not usually hits like clockwork at the
two-thirds mark of whatever you're
watching
in uh screenwriting we call this the
break into three uh
and this uh and for both episodes it was
around the 28 minute mark
and if you're being honest each of these
moments it's like a two-minute window of
things that you can kind of sync
two minutes to overlap with each other
pretty easily uh and if you watch any
hollywood movie
dude around 15 minutes in exactly some
inciting incident will happen
there is like a structure that unless
it's really boring
yeah unless it's uh not a typical
hollywood movie and it's just doing its
own thing
but i think we could say things like one
division and loki
are following formula pretty pretty
closely when it comes to timing these
things out uh but
more than that more than that i just
don't think the arrival of the scarlet
witch
was the thing that broke the timeline
because that would mean it would have to
be an accidental nexus event and he
remains eyes
now it could have been like obviously
nexus beings like wanda
are gonna be a dangerous blind spot for
kang but the implication of wanda's
vision of her future self in that
mind stone moment in episode eight
remember she saw the outline of her
future self as the scarlet witch
i think that implied that her becoming
the scarlet witch was destined
always part of the timeline which means
it was part of someone's timeline script
so i think maybe he remains saw that
eventuality but just didn't consider it
a major threat for him
because we know his script ran out at
some point
uh and that's gonna be some other king's
problem but
i think in the context of this loki
scene i think what caused the timeline
to unravel the way it did was the
connection between sylvia and loki
producing whatever their anomalistic
nexus event through their shared
intellect that broke he remains timeline
and made him obsolete so that another
king variant would have to take over
and i think it broke because it was
always destined to based on sylvie's
defiant individualism and her pension
for distrust and revenge
and if you're a writer working on loki
something that's cataclysmic as the
timeline shattering
is more meaningful if it's a consequence
of your protagonists not the result of
actions by some characters not even in
your show
so if we're talking about authorial
intent at least it would assume
that uh loki writers would say this was
probably just caused by loki or silly he
remains
another kang variant some combination of
that however
i don't want to say we shouldn't connect
these shows because yes i do believe
they are interconnected
that is my general theory as a crazy
marvel scientist that all these things
are connected
um and i believe that loki's timeline
explosion and one division's post-credit
scene are linked
because in that scene after some
unspecified time in this cabin reading
through the dark hold
only in that moment did wanda finally
hear her kids and that would imply that
something in the cosmos changed in order
to open that door
uh so i think i like to look at it this
way where loki caused
one division as opposed to one division
cause loki
because this way you don't need to think
about wanda vision or loki
being different than as was presented to
us when we watched it in order to do
this math
because it could just be as simple as
like we see a scene a doctor strange
multiverse madness where
wanda or doctor strange say suddenly the
multiverse just erupted into chaos
allowing realities to intersect we don't
know what caused it
so he's like me neither i don't know
yeah i
don't know i wasn't there they booed me
back into kang tva
so uh i think loki variants coming
together was what broke he who remains
timeline so that he had to kind of
retire allow
allow a more chaotic kang to rule
creating this multiverse of madness that
affected wanda and her post-credits
scene and we will see the fallout of
that in doctor strange multiverse
madness maybe even spider-man no way
home
but empty i want to know your thoughts
on this and if you do have a specific
take i
want to know what did you think uh he
remains dropped on his desk
in that moment like what was that all
about dude i like
played that moment over and over again
because i'm like what the hell does he
have
in his hand and i just can't point it
out and like i just i just
chalked it up to like you know this
amazing man jonathan majors
being the improv king that he is um
acting legend
was just like you know what i'm just
gonna pick this like random prop up
and just like demonstrate that like you
know like there's no
like i'm going off script and like you
know things are different now and
like maybe i'm in a just a new just a
new phase of the cosmos
um and so yeah i don't think that object
is all that
significant i think that he was just
like just just really feeling
weird about freestyling freestyling it
for the first time in eons
yeah but like what did he expect to
happen did he expect it not to fall
according to gravity but like float off
into space uh it was what
the script he thought i guess in that
moment was just his version of pinching
himself
you know yeah that's what i'm thinking
it's like it's like whoa it's like
cool like i can like this was not
predetermined i didn't know what this is
what was happening maybe it's a jurassic
park thing like you know malcolm where
he has the drop of water on laura dern's
knuckle
and then he's like you would think it
would roll one way or roll the same way
again but due to
little micro indentations on your hand
chaos the universe goes to chaos and
then it'll roll a different way so maybe
it wasn't the drop it was the way it hit
the desk it was supposed to bounce one
way
and then it bounced another way or it
didn't bounce and that's what blew his
mind in that moment
did we figure it out i think you did
dude i think that's the exact answer
but what do you what do you expect do
you do you think we will get uh some
kind of recontextualization of that one
division post-credits scene that
explains what really happened in that
moment do you think it'll be tied to
loki
um i think that you know the the
connection of
loki sort of causing that moment like
you said
um in that cabin in one division makes a
lot of sense because like
she's able to connect out to the
multiverse and before the multiverse was
tied together
by he who remains and so like it makes
logical sense
for that moment of her hearing her um
her children i don't know if they're
after you know their multiverse children
um that it makes sense for that for that
to be the thing however
we do have the um the factor that wanda
is the scarlet witch
so like i feel like wanda could pro
probably just communicate with the
multiverse or break through whatever
binding um he who remains uh
did on her own because she's just that
diesel of a being but
logically logically the events of loki
seem to
have happened first because everything's
sort of outside of time so i don't
first in quotation marks um before the
uh that that scene in one division yeah
i guess what's interesting about this
is that it seems like he remains slash
whatever kang
collective he's part of uh identified
loki and sylvie
as huge threats because of that nexus
event they created a lamentous one
um maybe the the two of them coming
together creates like a nexus being
but really i think they should be more
worried about the scarlet witch
because the only reason they were able
to thwart sylvie and loki is because
sylvie and loki as loki's are just uh
innately distrustful and they get
trapped in the game within the game
whereas wanda i don't think cares about
the game within the game
she has other priorities she is not as
selfish as these characters are
she has these kids she has her love for
vision you know
um i hey there's a counter argument
there that wanda
by trapping all of west view in her mind
hex
is selfish in a way because it's her own
grief but
that chaos uh makes her
in a way a bigger threat than loki is
because you can't there's no game to try
to corrupt with her
she is she is more sincere i think
in her uh motives she's not playing any
tricks
that you can get in like a a sherlock
moriarty chess game with
as uh he remains got him with loki and
silvi so
i'm surprised that i'm not surprised
this is just a story that they're
telling kang is the villain of loki
but uh i'm just it makes me curious to
see if kang is gonna
show up in some way in multiverse of
madness see like
here's something that like i brought up
the other day with my um
in my talk with uh jess during rogue
theory
about the nature of scarlet witch and
that like because he who remains
obviously is the kevin feige of the
marvel universe essentially
um and he essentially knew that the
advance of one division were going to
happen
maybe he's setting up wanda to be a
weapon
against the oncoming kangs that are
coming because he knows that the kings
are just super diesel
and that they are like they're gonna
conquer anyway so it's like i'm gonna
set up
this uh you know this mentally unstable
lady and she's gonna be a weapon and
she's gonna kind of just be a rogue
element because i don't know what she's
gonna do
but i know she's going to really make it
hard for these kegs to conquer
um so like you know maybe in an attempt
to like to truly find the best kang
because like it's the trial by fire
thing because
tanks can fight other kangs but like
what if it's kangs vs kang's versus
scarlet witch
like and like i i have this weird
feeling that there is probably a bigger
multiverse war going on than we we know
about because like we have to consider
the uh dormammu and what we know about
dormammu
and that he supposedly has conquered all
these other dimensions or
universes in the multiverse and we also
have kang who's also doing the same
thing as well
so kang and dermamu have probably
come to terms or like have come to butts
or something or i've been in a wars or
of some kind um or have at least talked
so i'm very interested to see how that
at least it's like i've taken their
broom and bumped on the ceiling
well we have several more questions we
want to get to first we want to thank
some friends who helped us make it
starting with our friends at movement
in a tiny apartment in southern
california two college dropouts teamed
up to create
a watch company that broke all the rules
with fair prices unexpected colors and
clean original designs movement grew
into
one of the fastest growing watch brands
shipping
to over 160 countries across the globe
and now movement has expanded into blue
light glasses that protect your eyes
from screens
expanded to minimalist jewelry and more
style essentials that don't break the
bank all designed out of their
california headquarters
on july 20th movement is celebrating
their eight year anniversary by running
a huge site-wide
sale everything is 28 off
that's right 28 off all their
best-selling watches their blue light
glasses their jewelry and more
i recently got the ocean plastic edition
watch for movement
it looks really cool it's super
functional and its case
strap and buckle are made entirely from
reclaimed ocean plastic pollution bro i
saw you wearing it the other day
it looked like pretty fancy i dug it i
like it i love it
uh movement is going all out for their
eighth birthday this is their biggest
sale of the year take advantage of these
price points before they go
don't miss movements biggest sale of the
year go to mvmt.com
marvel and enjoy your 28 off that's 28
off sitewide at mvmt.com
marvel join the movement we also want to
thank bluetooth for sponsoring this
episode our friends at blue chew have a
unique online service that delivers
these same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis but in chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost blue chew is an
online prescription service so no
doctor's office or pharmacy trips and
ships right to your door in a discreet
package
you sign up at bluetooth.com consult
with one of their licensed medical
providers and once you're approved you
receive your prescription within days
their licensed medical providers work
with you to find the right ingredient
and strength and blue chew is chewable
just like it says in the name
which is great news for folks that don't
like swallowing pills
so if you could benefit from some extra
confidence when it's time to perform
visit bluechew.com for more details and
important safety information and we got
a special deal for our audience
try blue chew for free when you use our
promo code inside marvel let's check out
just pay the five dollars in shipping
that's bluetooth.com promo code
insidemarvel to receive your first month
free and we thank bluechu
for sponsoring this show all right back
to loki empty
wait a day a minute why didn't mobius or
b15 recognize loki at all
like don't you think they should have at
least recognized the infamous god of
mischief
what does this tell us about this new
reality that they're in at the end of
the episode well
first of all i think that mobis and b15
didn't recognize locally
specifically uh to hurt our feelings
because
they knew it would hurt us and it did it
really did because that was his best
friend
um but no i think that the reason why
they didn't recognize loki
is probably because loki is in
the first ever loop of the tva
it's like this is the one that you know
kang
first started and so like this is why no
one knows who loki is because
they don't really have a whole lot of
experience pruning timelines yet and
they're like okay
our loki in this universe looks totally
different maybe it's richard e grant
loki maybe it's a completely different
loki like maybe that's why they call him
classic loki because he was from the
first
run of the um of the multiverse
uh loops but that's my theory what do
you think i think that's a really good
explanation empty i didn't think about
that my
take of it was that this was a uh kang
dominated
timeline now and because kang is such a
conqueror
that he went further and pruned all
loki's from birth like he made a reality
where it's not like
infinite loki's exist but reality where
like no loki's exist
uh and so the tva doesn't even know the
god of mischief because like maybe
there's some kind of alteration
where kang just went back to the source
to that uh battle with the frost giants
in 965 a.d
and prevented uh that young luffys and
child from being taken in by odin
and being taught as guardian magic by
frigga and growing up alongside thor
becoming the loki that we know
uh and that like you know maybe he who
remains is like no we don't need to do
that we can use loki's we can
just prune them when their next events
occur but we don't need to prune them
out of existence
uh and the kang the conqueror is like no
we're going to kill baby
no more loki's like that element of
chaos we can't risk it
take it out yeah um but i think
either way that's got to be the case
right because when
loki first walked into the tva in
episode one
a lot of these people were aware of who
he was and it wasn't just because there
was a sylvie variant like loki lafayson
is one of the more famous people in all
of
reality in the marvel world like he's a
celebrity to them
you know and i think they just treat him
like a run-of-the-mill
detainee um just to kind of like beat
him down
a bit you know um but like they're aware
of who they're they wouldn't
mistake him for an analyst you know uh
yeah that was crazy okay so our next
question of the day is wait a damn
minute
why did sylvie say she was pruned before
loki was born
yeah okay so this kind of like brings up
what
might just be you know to a lot of
people a plot hole that the show hasn't
really given an answer for
and i think mt you and i and a lot of
other people and a lot of other people
watching the show have just kind of
taken it for granted that this makes
sense
but it really doesn't necessarily like
so sylvie was pruned before loki was
born but if
it's all happening all at once how was
she pruned before he was born and i
think what this means it's kind of what
you were saying mt
is that the reason why all these
variants exist despite them coming from
timelines that are pruned despite
they're only supposed to be one sacred
timeline
why do we have a loki that's an
alligator or a loki that's a woman or a
loki that looks like richard e grant
or you know any of the other loki
variants that we see
uh their existence was not their nexus
events they didn't shape-shift into
these forms they were born the way they
are
looking the way they are but it's
because within the sacred timeline
it is really like a coaxial cable if you
were to cut open a coaxial cable yeah
there is a central cable
but there's like a bronze uh weave
you know there's like a mesh weave or
like a think of a bundle of rope or like
a hair braid or something like that
or like a twizzler a twizzler
it is really a cord that is uh
woven tightly with a ton of other cords
that if you cut it it frays
and i think that's what this is really
is it's a
collective of a bunch of smaller chords
a bunch of smaller timelines
that all kind of weave together and
don't interfere with each other
and when you cut it uh or when you break
it
one of those starts to fray off and if
too many of them start to fray off it
all comes apart
so i think uh that is what the sacred
timeline
is and i think the show didn't
necessarily give us that for
visual as much but within that one
sacred timeline there is a separate
reality where loki was an alligator a
separate one where it's
uh sylvie a separate one where it's
boastful loki a separate one where it's
classic loki
a separate one where it was president
loki and none of them interfered and
none of them
created a a kang and when they do
the kang timeline gets pruned i think
the nexus event for each of them is they
did something different in their life
that led to an eventuality where kang
would rise
so the fact that he who remains his
prerogative was to prevent
other kangs from forming i think that
tells us it's not about loki it was it
was about kang really
um but yeah so when sylvie said i was
pruned before loki was born maybe that
was the writer's version of trying to
explain this that the sacred timeline is
kind of what you were saying
mt it's like a it's a loop it's just
going round and round and round and
round and each time it loops back it's
a new chord gets formed within exactly
right exactly
that's exactly what i would answer too
because like that's it's precisely
what's going on it's like
with that first uh with the tva that we
find
loki in that i suspect to be the first
ever loop that's the first
chord in the coaxial cable and then the
next loop will do the second
chord and then like it keeps going like
you said and then it's making this
one super coaxial um
just sacred timeline uh multiverse
chord it's very weird and when the
timeline breaks though we're seeing
those initial phrases but then it just
spills out into a spider web you know
and i think that's that's what that is
supposed to mean um but all these things
still
existed within the timeline uh all these
things were kind of existing in a kind
of harmony
altogether but what is interesting about
it is it's almost like
while it's a sacred timeline if it is
one is it one loop that's tightly coiled
i get like a slinky that's smushed
together
and if you're to stretch out a slinky it
is just one string of metal
or plastic or whatever it is um so is
the idea that like
i think that's why it's hard for a lot
of people to wrap their minds around it
because like it's oh
it's one thing to say that time is not
linear it's another thing to say that
it loops back on itself at the end of
time so does it mean like
there's some inevitable millions
billions of years from now the end of
the universe where it just
unravels so much everything explodes or
something
and then it resets like a level of mario
and it goes back to the big bang and
that explosion is just the big bang
and it and it because when people say
time is a flat circle it's like well
then what causes the reset if time is a
flat circle
exactly you just said yes
no no no like no like no like what
causes the reset exactly
that's a good point and like you know i
think there could be like a big crunch
situation
where um you know everything just goes
together and
causes the big bang but no that's a
that's a really good point like those
are all very valid points
but i think that's what like we did
start to see in the opening
animation of episodes that's exactly
what i think you know like we saw
we zoomed out from our solar system our
galaxy our universe
and then it all condensed in a sphere
that exploded
into a big bang but like those planets
would not have existed before the big
bang so it's almost like saying the big
bang
is the reset point over and over and
over again spewing
infinity stones into the universe
creating different planets causing these
planetary body
bodies to collide stars to form you know
solar systems to form
and then eventually it reaches a point
of critical mass again and explodes
again
and that each time is the coil reset i
think that's the big crunch man like
everything
the big big the big bang happens and
then like let's all the matter
spreading out and then the big crunch is
all the matter coming back in forming a
little ball
and then the big bang happens again so
like it's
i think that that could be the exact
loop that we're we're seeing and that's
what causes the big bang
and that could be a potential thing that
um this is
this is actually something i've been
thinking about the big crunch and i
think that's this could be
what the collector is preparing for
because like you got to remember that
the collector in guardians one
he's not just collecting because he's a
freak i mean that's a big reason why
he's collecting
and he's a terrible person but he's he's
also um
described his character uh benicio del
toro as like a noah
and like he's collecting all of these
these um creatures
for a specific thing that he's doing
and he since he's one of the first
beings to ever exist in
all of time and space because if he's an
elder of the universe i think that he
sees
this big um crunch coming up and he's
like you know what the universe is about
to be rebooted
i got my arc ready to roll so
you know i don't know but that's just me
that's such a cool theory
um i hope it's true um we have uh some
time to answer a few questions we'll try
to do these rapid fire just a few of
these uh wait a damn minute what do you
think sylvie will do now
what's her next step from that citadel
hmm um she could do pretty much anything
because now she has that ultimate
10-pad wrist thingy that was left behind
by kang when he passed away
unfortunately by mysterious
circumstances
um but uh i think that she could
maybe try to lead a tva of her own um
because she does have the power
and you know it would sort of be really
interesting because like
she goes after the guy that um you know
affected her life and
changed so many people's lives that like
maybe when loki runs into her neck she's
like
i became the thing that i hated the most
and i think that'd be really interesting
for her character
um just dive into like the you know the
responsibility of power
which is what he remains struggled with
but yeah yeah
i think she's gonna go on a killing
spree to kill every kang that she can
whack-a-mole style
and it's never gonna be enough for her
and she's gonna go one and each time
when she kills one he's gonna say see
you soon and she's like
ah i didn't get the right one she's
gonna go one by one and eventually she's
gonna get to
young nathaniel richards iron lad of the
young avengers
and he's gonna be like oh no no i don't
want to be gang she's like i'm going to
kill you
he's like don't be good i'll be good i
promise and then that will lead him to
become iron man
i think oh that'd be really interesting
it's like hey like he changes his mind
because sylvie
shows him who he could become but i love
that yeah i love that
i dig it um here's a question wait a
damn minute some people have been
pointed out how casey's evidence card
got pruned back in episode one
suggesting that it should have gotten
the void right so is there a drawer full
of infinity stones in the void now that
someone could use
yeah i mean sure that seems that like
that's the logical thing and someone's
gonna find it
um hopefully uh the one-armed loki
because he could get himself another arm
that way but
yeah you know or elijah ate it and is
having terrible heartburn
yeah he just has to pass those stones
yeah which is gonna be really rough for
him i mean in the past i've theorized
that like
uh the reason the stones weren't usable
in the
tva is because like you can't use magic
in the tva like loki can't use his
sorcery and that's why sylvie's
enchantment didn't really work
but in the void it's different they
totally use their enchantment and their
magic in the void
but i also wonder if like when you make
a
an infinity stone redundant wherever you
take it it loses its power
is my theory that like it's not usable
like the fact that it's not one of a
kind anymore
makes it it neutralizes it that's kind
of my thinking
it makes it easier because otherwise
it's it opens too many possibilities
i think that you know just given
by this the ancient one's explanation of
the time stream in the in the universe
in in uh
in avengers endgame because the ancient
one said that the infinity stones create
what we perceive as
time so like anybody within the time
stream
can use the infinity stones because the
infinity stones kind of make the time
stream but when you exit the time screen
and enter the tva it's like you are no
longer within infinity stone realm
so therefore these rocks are useless
good answer good answer
uh one final question that we'll ask for
this episode throg
how did he get in the jar what is his
backstory
well i think i will i really like to
think that
throgg and gator loki arrived in the
at the void at the same time and then
frog was like okay loki
let's get let's do get help and gator
look he's like we're not doing get help
and he just puts him in the jar
and shows him underground i don't know
how he manages to put him in the jar
because he doesn't have opposable thumbs
but gator lucky will find a way
yeah um how do you think it's wrong uh
i i guess the question is is was this a
thor
that was turned into throgg or is this a
throg that was always a throg
um i'm willing to bet this is a reality
where thor
was turned into a frog and that was
a nexus event for some look that led to
a reality where loki could create kang
or something like that so it was pruned
um so i think it tells us more about the
loki from the reality it came from than
the thor from that reality
honestly yes because like the jar was
right outside
the loki secret base right so like yeah
that does make sense for him to be a
thor that was turned into a frog by a
mischievous loki and i think the mjolnir
was put right there
just to taunt him uh yes but what you
would think that if he could pull
the mjolnir he would be able to power up
like he could summon it but maybe this
throg is not worthy of that mjolnir
maybe it's a mjolnir from another
timeline and so across timelines
the worthiness charm doesn't work even
though an end game though i guess
future thor was able to summon that
and that was they were in a variant
timeline at that point
it's true but i think it maybe wasn't
variant until he pulled
mjolnir i think that what could have
happened
now that i'm thinking about it is that
what if this is the thor
that kid loki said that he killed
because he left him in a jar
underground he was like i killed thor
and because after he turned him into a
frog
and thor is underground he doesn't he
doesn't see
that mjolnir's there so he doesn't try
to summon him because he's in the dark
only we can see it
from our point of view so he's just
trying to get out
but he's just like right in front of the
owner and he has no idea yeah he's just
like ah
and it's like this is loki's torture
yeah he's like yeah he has no
clue well uh we're gonna keep talking
about loki in the weeks ahead but that
is it for this episode of inside marvel
mt and i are going to be back every
wednesday to continue unpacking loki
and to answer all your biggest marvel
questions as we wait for the premiere of
what if
on august 11th and of course don't
forget to check out our many great loki
merch options at nyrocstarsmerch.com
follow mt at mastertainment follow me
eddie avos follow new rockstars
subscribe to inside marvel wherever you
get your podcast thanks for watching see
you next time bye
[Music]
you